hey welcome to draft academy my name is
mike in this course i'm going to cover
everything you need to know to get
started writing html html stands for
hyper text markup language and it's
basically just a language that we can
use to create web pages so if you've
ever been on the internet almost every
single page on the internet was written
in this language called html and in html
you can define series of html tags which
will define the layout and the look and
the feel
of your website so if you can learn what
those html tags are and if you can learn
where to put them and how to use them
together then you can build your own
website it's actually a lot easier than
people think to build a custom website i
mean so often people will run off to use
like content management systems or they
use programs to build websites for them
but sometimes it's fun to just go in and
get your hands dirty and start building
a website from scratch and you're going
to learn how to do that in this course
in this course i'm going to cover the
basics of using html so from the first
lesson on to the last lesson you're
going to be writing html you're going to
be learning new tags and you're going to
be learning new ways to manipulate a web
page to make it look and feel the way
that you want it to html is an
invaluable skill i mean even just
putting html experience on your resume
could help you get a job one day or it
could just be something cool that you
could brag to your friends about as
awesome as it is i think sometimes
people can be a little bit intimidated
to try and learn html because it seems
like there's so much to learn and it
seems so complicated i'm here to tell
you that it's actually really easy to
learn and i'm going to be here with you
throughout the entire course walking you
through all of the basics trust me i've
known html for a while so i know what's
worth learning and what's not we're
going to cover everything that you need
we're going to talk about all the
important things and by the end of this
course you're going to have a true and
full understanding of what html is how
to use it and how to build your own
website
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about choosing a text editor for html
now whenever you're writing html you're
actually writing it inside of what's
called an html file so this is a file
just a lot like a text file but instead
of a dot txt or a docx extension we have
a dot html extension so with html you're
basically just writing these html files
and then your web browser is able to
take those files and display them as web
pages and it's sort of this really cool
thing but the first step in writing html
is picking some program that you can use
to write these html files in there's a
bunch of different options when you're
trying to choose an html text editor and
i think a lot of times it can get a
little bit confusing or maybe even a
little bit overwhelming just because
there's so many options and so many
people have different opinions on which
is the best editor and you know what's
the best thing for beginners to do in
this video i just want to give you an
overview of like what are your options
and then maybe give you some
recommendations as far as like where to
start so with html text editors really
all you need is just a simple text
editor so any text editor that you have
which is capable of editing files and
saving them in different formats is
going to work for you and generally when
you're writing html you don't want to
use like a word processing program
there's a lot of word processors out
there uh you know microsoft word google
docs libreoffice these are like these
big word processing programs and this is
generally not something that you want to
use so you don't want to be typing out
your html inside of a you know microsoft
word that's um kind of an overkill when
you're writing html the simpler the
better so a lot of times for beginners
people will recommend that you use the
just very simple text editor that you
have on your computer on windows it's
going to be notepad on mac it's like
textedit and these are just the bare
bones simple text editors and it's
actually more than enough that you need
to write html and so like i said
generally for beginners writing html in
something simple like notepad or
textedit really forces you to focus on
writing the html and you have to type
out every single line and you have to
really look to make sure that
everything's formatted correctly and
ultimately it'll just help you to really
grasp the fundamentals but if you're
somebody who doesn't want to use like
notepad or text edit you can actually
use a specially designed program and
there's a bunch of these programs out
there which are specially designed to
write html in some of the popular
programs there's one called atom sublime
brackets text wrangler webstorm there's
a bunch of these different programs that
have been developed by different
companies and you can go online and do a
bunch of research but
essentially what these are are programs
that are specially designed to help you
write your html so they'll take the html
and they might display it differently
they might give you the ability to use
like add-ons or different features that
will make writing html a little bit
easier but as a penalty for that they're
also a little bit more complicated to
use and so like i said generally for
beginners like the less complicated
things are the better so you may want to
err more on the side of doing something
simple and then once you learn html move
up to one of these other programs i want
to show you sort of the difference in
what
these might look like
so over here i have text edit and this
is just the default like text editor on
macs so if i open this you'll see here i
have this file and this is actually an
html file
so inside of this file i have written a
bunch of html and this is like the
simplest html document you're ever going
to see but this is what writing html
would look like in something like this
and so if i wanted to add some more html
down here i could just type it out
and
you know it's very simple there's
nothing to configure there's nothing to
add on you just sort of write out your
html
but something more complicated would be
a program like this this is called adam
and this is one of those text editors i
was talking about
and this makes it you know a little bit
easier for you to write the html you can
see it's formatted a little bit
differently right so
this is the same code by the way so over
here these little tags are color this is
colored up here so there's different
colors generally programs like this will
allow you to choose different themes so
i could you know make the whole look in
the feel of this different so there's a
lot of really cool options and
configuration options that you can use
with a text editor like this but what
you also need to understand is writing
html in this is doing exactly the same
thing as this doing functionally these
are the same thing they're just
you know it's an environment for us to
write html in so here's my
recommendation to you i would definitely
recommend and a lot of people recommend
this starting with a simple text editor
like this it doesn't have to be um
text edit but it can be something simple
and the whole idea is that the simpler
the better when you're first learning
html you don't want to have to worry
about you know configuring different
things or working with some heavy text
editor you know using something light
and simple like text edit is just going
to allow you to focus on the html and
then once you have a grasp for writing
html and you really feel comfortable
doing it then you can move up to a
program like this now obviously that's
just my recommendation you don't have to
listen to me
and if you do want to choose a program
like this
definitely do your research try out a
couple different programs see which one
fits for you you're going to hear a lot
of people online saying like this text
editor is the best or that one's the
best you know people always get into
little fights about those things but the
best text editor is the one that is
right for you and so it's the one that
you enjoy using the most don't listen so
much to what other people are saying the
best way to pick is just to try a bunch
of these different text editors and as
you go through this course even you can
try a bunch of different ones and see
how you like using each one but again
for beginners i would recommend starting
simple html is a really simple language
and so the less you can bog it down with
like all these plugins and add-ons and
themes like the better it is because
with web development and just
programming in general it's usually the
simpler and the more straightforward
something is the better it is
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about creating your first html file so
i'm going to show you how to create an
html file i'll show you how you can view
that html file on your web browser and
i'll show you how to set up your html
file with some default html code in
order to make it work properly so the
first thing i'm going to do is create a
folder for my project so i'm going to
create a folder that i can put my html
files in for my website over here in my
file explorer i'm just going to make a
new folder
and
i'm just going to call this
ga underscore site for draft academy
site
and then now what we can do is open up
this folder inside of my text editor so
i'm going to come over here and i'll
just add this project folder
and now inside of this folder i'm going
to create a new file so i'm going to say
new file
and i'm just going to call this
index.html
now the reason i'm naming this file
index.html is because generally when
you're creating your first web page you
want to name it index.html index.html is
a special file name that we can use and
if a file is named index.html and it's
at the root directory of your folder
then your web browser will think that
that's the home page of your website so
if you're just creating one web page
like this it's a good idea for us to
name it
index.html but really you can name it
whatever you want i'm going to name mine
index.html
and so now we have our html file open so
this is actually a
file now that we can use and view on our
web browser so if i just came over here
and typed hello world
i can actually
take this file and i'm just going to
open it up inside of my web browser so
i'm going to click open
open with and then i'll open it with my
web browser so i'm going to open it with
google chrome
and now what will happen is you'll see
this file will open up
and over here on the web browser we have
our text so this is like the simplest
purest form of html which is just typing
out some bare bones text inside of an
html file and it'll display here on our
screen but if we want to have an html
file that's like an official file and
that's structured correctly we're
actually going to have to add in some
extra code in here
so i'm going to get rid of this and
we're going to create what's called an
html tag
now html is a language that's used to
define
layouts for web pages and we can define
those layouts using things called tags
so i can create a series of tags and
those tags will basically tell my web
browser how i want my website to look
and what content i want to have on my
website
so in order to kind of
start creating our html file we're going
to have to create a basic skeleton of
html tags and these are just standard
tags that every html file is going to
have and they're basically going to give
our browser different information about
what's in our file so up here the first
tag that i want to create is going to be
called doctype and we're basically going
to define what the document type of this
file is going to be and
we're going to create an html file so
i'm going to type an exclamation point
d-o-c-t-y-p-e
all caps just like that
and then i want to say html so this tag
is basically telling my web browser the
type of this document is html so this is
an html document
and now down here i can start creating
what are called container tags so this
is a single tag we only need one of
these tags but in html there's a lot of
tags which are called container tags and
it basically means that there's two tags
so there's a starting tag and there's an
ending tag and you can put other tags
inside of them so they act as containers
for either content or other html tags
and the first one we're going to create
is just called the html tag so i'm going
to make a less than sign html
and a greater than sign
and now i can close off this tag so this
is the starting tag and i want to create
an ending tag so i'm going to create
that down here and the way that you
create an ending tag is you take the
name of the starting tag
and you basically just put a forward
slash before it and then you type out
the name of the starting tag so
this is now a pair of tags and you can
see
the relationship right so up here we
have the starting tag so html is the
name of this tag you could say that this
is an html tag
and this is the ending tag so it uses
that same name but it uses this forward
slash so that forward slash is used to
denote that this is the ending tag and
this html tag is going to be necessary
for any html files that you have this is
basically like the highest level tag in
our website it's like the overall
container tag for our website and so all
of the html code and html tags are going
to go inside of here so now there's two
other sets of tags that i need to create
the first set is called the head tags
and the second is called the body tags
so in any html file there's two basic
sections there's the head of the
document and then there's the body of
the document and the head of the
document defines data about the document
so
we can define things like the title of
the document we can give the document a
description
we could define other attributes about
the document like maybe an image that's
associated to the document we can also
use the head to
import any resources that we need into
our html file so you'll find out later
that we can actually link this html file
to other types of files and inside of
the head we can do all of that so the
head is sort of like the settings of the
html file it's like the command center
it's sort of like metadata
about the actual file and we can create
the head by creating head tags so it's
going to be a less than sign we're going
to type head
and now we can close off this tag
just like that
and now i'm going to create a body tag
so the body tag is where we're going to
put like the meat and the bones of the
html page so the body tag is where all
of our html content is going to go
generally the body is going to be a lot
bigger than the head the body is going
to be where you're actually putting all
the content for your web page so
anything that's in the body for the most
part is going to show up or at least
it's going to get rendered by the
browser now down here i'm just going to
make these body tags so i'm going to say
body
and we'll make another closing tag
body and so
i'm defining all of these different tags
and when i open this file up inside of
my web browser the web browser is able
to look through all of these tags and
figure out information about the page so
the web browser can actually like parse
through all of these different tags and
it can figure out how to display all of
the information so you can define
information and you can use tags to help
define that information and lay out that
information differently and the web
browser will be able to parse through
all of that and basically decipher it
and use it to build a website so it's
really cool
now one thing i want to point out is the
way that i'm formatting everything so
you'll notice here that i have these
html tags
and inside of these html tags i have
this head tag and i have this body tag
so i want to point out the relationship
between all of these tags and i'm also
going to introduce you guys to some
terminology the first thing you want to
notice is that i'm indenting the head
tag and i'm indenting the body tag so
you can see there's like a couple spaces
here this is basically just a tab
and generally when you're writing html
you want to indent all of your files and
so the rules for indenting are basically
like we have this container right so i
have this html tag and this html tag and
inside of here we have the head and the
body so any tags that are inside other
tags you want it indent
and so it's just like this right this
head tag is inside of this html tag so
i'm indenting it same thing with the
body i'm indenting it and that will
basically visually help you to decipher
the relationships between the tags
and we can actually define the
relationships with these tags and one of
the most common ways to do that is with
like uh family terminology so we would
refer to this html tag up here as the
parent of this head tag and this body
tag so the body tag is the child of the
html tag because it's inside of it so if
you're ever talking to like html
developers a lot of times they'll use
that terminology they'll say like oh the
head tag is the child of the html tag so
i could ask you like
what's the parent of this body tag and
the answer would be the html tag because
the body tag is inside of the html tag
we would also define the head tag and
the body tag as siblings so these would
be sibling tags because they share the
same parent and so you can kind of
understand that relationship so if i was
to create a series of tags inside of
here um another tag we can make is like
a paragraph actually you wouldn't want
to put it in the head we want to put it
in the body
so i could create a paragraph tag and
don't worry too much about what
paragraph tags are we're going to get
into that but
this
paragraph tag would be the grandchild of
this html tag and it would be the child
of this body tag so that's kind of like
some terminology that you're going to
hear a lot you know
generally we're defining these html tags
in terms of like generational syntax so
parent child grandparent you get the
point so now that we have this basic
html skeleton laid out we essentially
have everything that we need for
this website and so i can refresh or i
can save this page and i'm actually
going to head over here into my browser
and now when we refresh this page you'll
see that nothing happens so this is a
completely blank
html document it's like the simplest
html document that we could ever write
so i'm going to show you one more tag
that you can use and this is called the
title tag so up here in the head of the
document i'm going to create another tag
called title
and this tag
we're going to put some information in
here so generally when you have html
tags certain tags are meant as
containers so for example this html set
of tags is a container it's basically
used to hold other tags but certain tags
are used to hold content so this title
tag is used to hold text and so inside
of these title tags we want to put text
and this is going to be the title of my
website so i could say like mike's
website and this is going to now be the
official title of our website and you'll
notice that if i come over here to my
web browser look up here at this tab you
can see the title up here is currently
index.html that's the name of the file
but when i refresh this file you'll see
that it updates to mike's website and so
this is a good example of the browser is
able to parse through our website and
it's able to read these title tags and
figure out what the title of our website
is so these are the kind of tags that
you can put inside of your head or like
title tags you know tags that are
defining information about the html
document and so down here in the body
tag i could put any content that i want
to have inside of my webpage so i can
put like
hello
world down here
and now when i refresh the page it'll
show up in my web browser
so that's how you want to go writing out
content on your website any of the
content is going to go inside of these
body tags and throughout the rest of
this course we're going to get into all
the cool tags that you can put inside
this body tag seriously there's so many
of these awesome tags in html and
there's so many tags that can help us to
do awesome things inside of our web
browser so i hope you stick around and
we'll learn how to put stuff inside the
body
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about using some basic html tags so
we're going to look at some of the most
common html tags that you're going to be
using in your website and we'll use them
to define a pretty good looking site so
by the end of this video you'll have a
good idea of how to lay out a bunch of
content inside of html and display it on
your browser
the first tag that i want to show you is
a tag that actually is going to go up
here in the head of our document and i'm
gonna put it right here above the title
and right now i just have a basic
skeleton of an html file it's sort of
like the simplest version of an html
file
and one thing that i want to do is
define something called a meta tag and a
meta tag is basically a tag that defines
information about our file so it's
giving us metadata
so i can use this less than sign and i'm
going to define this meta tag
and i'm basically just going to use this
to define the character encoding for my
web page so this is basically just
telling the web browser what types of
characters i'm using inside of this
document so i can say
char set
is equal to and then inside of these
quotation marks i'm just going to say
utf
hyphen
8 and this will define the character set
for my document as utf-8 which is like a
really common character set it's the
character set that i'm using so like i
said this is a meta tag and it's used to
define information about our file
i'm going to define one more meta tag
and this is going to be a meta
description tag and so we can use this
tag to basically give a description for
our website and this tag can be used by
things like web browsers so for example
google could go into our file look at
this meta tag and it can use it to
display information on its search pages
so generally when you search for
something on google a lot of times
there'll be like a little description of
it and they're using this tag from the
file so i can say
meta and i'm going to say name
is equal to
description
and now i'm going to say
content
is equal to
and now i can type the description for
my website so i could say like
this is an awesome website
and now we have this description which
is just like this is an awesome website
and i'm going to go ahead and end this
tag
so i want to show you guys uh one
concept or you know one thing in html
which is uh
html attributes now we have these html
tags so this is a meta tag right here
this is a meta tag but inside of these
tags we have things called attributes
sometimes people call them attributes
sometimes people call them properties
basically we're passing this tag some
information so
i have my meta tag and i'm giving this
tag some custom information so inside of
this meta tag
i'm telling it what type of information
i want to define so i'm telling it that
i want to define a description and i'm
telling it what that description should
be so a lot of times in these html tags
you can pass them attributes or
properties and those tags will be able
to use those attributes and properties
to do their job so this meta tags job is
to define metadata about the file and
when we pass it these attributes and
properties we're giving it the
information that it needs to define that
metadata so a lot of times inside of our
html tags we're going to have different
attributes and we're going to have to
give those tags different information so
just keep that in mind and these meta
tags kind of do a good job of showing
that because they take like this one
takes two attributes so those are two
tags that we can define up here in the
head of our document now let's move down
into the body of our document and we'll
start having some fun so the body of the
document is where we can put all of like
the actual content for our website so
all the stuff that you see on the
website is generally going to go here
inside the body
now
the first tag i want to show you guys is
basically a tag that we can use to
define a
header or like a title on our website so
over here i have this hello world but
i'm just gonna get rid of that because i
don't really like it imagine that i
wanted to give my website a heading
right so i wanted to define like the
heading for my website
well over here i can use something
called a heading tag and the way that we
write this heading tag is with lesson
sign
and i'm going to use this h and then
after h i'm gonna give this a number so
i can give this a number either one
through six so i can give it a two three
four five or a six
and this will basically spit out a
header for our website so header one
let's just say that this is gonna be
mike's
website
and i'm gonna use this ending tag right
here so this is an example of a tag
that's gonna take some text input inside
of it and now when i go over here and i
refresh my page you'll notice that
mike's website shows up and it's nice
and big right so i have this nice big
header on my website and it's you know
the text is really big and it looks
really good and in addition to defining
an h1 i could also make this an h2 and
so now when i make this an h2 it's going
to be a little bit smaller so you see
that it shrunk a little bit and i can
make this an h4 and it's going to shrink
even more
and i could go all the way down to an h6
which is the smallest size of header
that html is going to allow us to define
and that's going to be a pretty small
header so anytime you want to sort of
like announce something or you want to
like title maybe like a section of a
document you can use these headers and
the headers will look a little bit
bigger and bolder than just normal text
would so in addition to having a header
maybe we'll leave this as an h2
i can also define just regular textual
information so i could define like a
paragraph on my website
and if you're writing like an article or
a webpage a lot of times you're going to
want to use a paragraph right you're
going to want to have some text on your
website so i can make what's called a
paragraph tag and a paragraph tag is
just gonna be p
and then we're also gonna need an ending
tag and now any text that i write in
here is gonna go inside of its own
paragraph so i could write like this is
my
paragraph
and now when i refresh my page you'll
see that this text showed up in its own
paragraph and what's cool about
paragraphs is that they'll automatically
sort of format themselves so i could
actually make another paragraph right
below this
so we could say this is another
paragraph
and this paragraph will automatically
space itself out and it'll be below this
other paragraph okay so
we have this paragraph and then we have
this paragraph and they're kind of just
like lined up like that and you can put
as much text as you want inside these
paragraphs and generally whenever you're
writing out like a block of text you're
going to want to use this paragraph tag
now we can also style some of the
elements inside of this paragraph so
let's say that i wanted this word here
paragraph to be bolded well i can use
another special html tag which is the
bold tag and this will make this word
bold so i can do less than sign and the
bold tag is just a b
and then
you want to end it over here so
inside of these open and closed bold
tags we can put any of the text inside
of a paragraph or inside of another
place in our website
that we want to be bold so now when i
refresh this page you'll see that
paragraph is bold i can also use another
tag so instead of making it bold we can
make it italicized so i could use an i
right here instead of a b
and now instead of being bold this text
is going to be italicized and you can
actually
embed these tags inside one another so i
could use the bold tags and the italics
tags so over here i'll take this bold
tag
and i'll take this other ending bold tag
and inside of the bold tags i'm going to
put the italics tags and then i'm going
to put the paragraph
and now we'll have a bold italics
paragraph just like that so it's just
italicizing one of the words and bolding
the word at the same time so that's a
really great way for you to you know you
could italicize certain words or you can
build certain words and it really makes
it easy just by using those tags another
thing that we can do is we can control
the layout of the document so one of the
things with html is that it lays out our
web pages in a very specific way and i
want to kind of show you how that
happens so when html lays out our web
page it basically takes the layout that
we define here inside the body and
displays it over here on the web page so
the order that we have the elements here
in the document is the order that
they're going to show up on the browser
so if i was to
cut out this paragraph and paste it up
here above the header
now my documents
layout and structure will reflect that
so now the paragraph is going to be
above the website
the website header and then this other
paragraph's going to be below it so the
way that you order these
tags inside of html is the way that
they're going to show up on the website
and the other thing is html doesn't
necessarily care about the way that we
format this file so in other words html
doesn't care about the white space in
other words if i made two extra lines
here you might think okay now there's
going to be two extra lines between the
paragraph and the title right because
there's all this space inside of here
but that's actually not the case
when i refresh the page nothing happens
html lays itself out and orders itself
out using these tags and so it doesn't
care about any of this white space
that's inside of our files it really
just cares about what's inside these
tags so imagine that we wanted to create
some white space right
and i'm just going to put this header
back up here so it's a little bit easier
to read
i could actually create a new line so
let's say here inside of this after this
header two i wanted to make a new line i
can use another html tag which is called
a break and the break tag will basically
create a new line in our html document
so i can just do a lesson sign a br and
then we're gonna do a forward slash and
we're gonna do a greater than sign and
you'll see now when i refresh this page
there should be a space between the
title and between this first paragraph
so you can see that we have this space
here and you can use as many of these
break tags as you want i can make two of
them and now it's going to be even
further down so these break tags can be
really good to kind of break things up
another tag that i can use is called the
horizontal rule tab and the horizontal
rule tab will basically give us a
straight line right across the website
that's going to help us to separate some
of our content so i can make that tag i
can say hr and then i'm going to do a
forward slash
and i'm going to do a greater than sign
and so you'll notice that this hr tag
was a lot like that br tag that we used
before and this is another special type
of html tag so this is a tag that's
called a single tag right so over here
in this header two we have one tag and
then we have this other ending tag but
sometimes there'll be tags for example
like this horizontal rule tab where you
don't really need two tags like there's
nothing that needs to go inside of them
and so it's just gonna be a single tag
and a lot of times
with these single tags you'll format
them this way so you'll write out the
name and then you'll use this ending
sign and then you use this greater than
sign and actually in certain cases you
can actually just get rid of this
forward slash but we're going to keep it
in because it's like technically correct
html so now you'll see that instead of a
break here we're going to have a
horizontal line and this horizontal line
is basically just something we could use
to break up our content right you could
put uh you could even put like another
one in here and it might style it right
so you could have like a double line
there whatever and the horizontal rule
will go all the way across the page
there's also a couple other tags that we
can use to control the size of our text
so down here in this paragraph let's say
that we wanted to make
one of these words bigger for example
let's say we wanted to make this bigger
right here we can use two tags called
big and small and they'll actually make
our
text a little bit bigger or smaller so
i can do the big tag here
and i'll do the ending tag so this works
just like all those other tags where
anything that goes inside of this big
tag is actually going to get bigger so
now watch this this right here when i
refresh my page
it's actually going to get a little bit
a little bit bigger and you can see that
it did and so i could do the same thing
with this is tag down here let's make
this bigger as well just to really
illustrate this
and now when i refresh this page
the is tag is also going to get bigger
so it doesn't get that much bigger but
you can use this to kind of control how
the text looks like maybe you want some
text to be a little bit bigger or
smaller i can do the same thing but with
small tags so here on this my word i'm
going to give this a small tag so we'll
say small
and then again we're going to end it
and now watch the my right here this is
going to get smaller
so you can see that it shrunk a little
bit so using those big and those small
tags can help us to control the size of
the text on our website we can also use
other tags uh called subscripts and
superscripts so this can be used to
format like subscripts and superscripts
especially if you're doing something
like math you're going to want to use
something like this so i'm going to go
over here into this paragraph
and we'll create a subscript and a
superscript so imagine that i wanted to
like type out the
chemical formula for water right we
could say
h2o
but this 2 should actually be a
subscript right it should be like a
small little two right down
below h so i can use this
sub tag
and i can surround this too with the sub
tag
and now this is going to be like a
little bit smaller so you'll see here we
have h2o so it's formatted correctly i
could also do the same thing with a
superscript so
another good example would be like math
so i could say like maybe we wanted to
write out 10 squared so like 10 to the
power of 2.
i can use this superscript
tag and this will make this a
superscript
so now we have 10 squared so these are
all like little html tags that you can
basically just use to format the text on
your website and when html was first
written you have to understand that
websites were just all textual so
nowadays we have like a bunch of images
and videos and all these different
things on our web pages but you know
generally html was just used to write
out text and there were some images and
some other stuff but there's a lot of
html tags that just deal with formatting
your text so these are all tags that can
come in handy and you can definitely use
them to format text inside of your
paragraphs or you can use any of these
tags inside of other elements so
i don't want you to think you can that
you can only use these tags inside of
like a paragraph you can use these tags
anywhere that there's text on your
website so we could use these up here in
the header or you could use them in any
other html tag that you want so those
are just some basic tags obviously
there's a bunch of these tags that we
can learn and we're going to get into
more of them but what you want to do is
really get a handle for the basics and
so this is really like the basics of
html things like headers horizontal
rules breaks paragraphs
get a handle for the basics and practice
like fleshing out different websites
using only these things and then when
you move on to more complex html you'll
be better off for it because you know
the fundamentals
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about comments in html
now comments are basically little pieces
of text that you can write inside of
your html which will be ignored by the
browser and generally the purpose of
comments is for either yourself to read
or for other developers to read so you
can write an html comment inside of your
html code and it'll be completely
ignored by the web browser but if for
example you come back to your code later
you might leave yourself a little
reminder or you could explain what a
little block of code is doing or if you
give your file to another developer you
can use comments to give them little
notes now i'm going to show you how you
can use comments inside of html and then
we're also going to talk about
comments best practice so like how can
you use comments the best way in html
the way that you can create a comment is
by
using a very particular syntax and so i
can create a comment by using a less
than sign an exclamation point and then
two hyphens so now you can see here in
my text editor that the when i put the
second hyphen in here like the look of
the comment actually changed
and that's because now we're in a
comment and so any text that i type is
going to be grayed out so this text
looks different from the text out here
and basically that's just to indicate
that okay we have now an html comment
one of the things i want to point out is
that when i created this comment all of
the code below it
turned also into this little comment so
now what i'm doing is i'm creating an
opening tag for a comment so a comment
is going to go inside of these opening
and closing tags and i can close off
this comment tag by using a
hyphen hyphen and a greater than sign so
now anything inside of these tags is
going to be a comment and i can run
these comments
down across multiple lines so i can
create comments you know that span a
couple different lines in our text and
like i said comments are basically just
special pieces of text that aren't going
to get rendered by the browser so
generally the browser's not just going
to not going to look at them they're
just going to kind of ignore them
and in here you can just put little
notes so i could say like
to do like i need to work on this
or i could say
you know don't display this you know
really any comment that you want to put
i mean it really doesn't matter but
comments can definitely be useful and
you're going to want to know how to use
comments you can also use comments to
comment out
specific pieces of code so
let's say for example that i didn't want
this
h2 and this horizontal rule to show up
so that's like this header over here on
my website i could take this and
surround it with comments
and now this basically just won't show
up on my website
and you can see because the browser's
ignoring it so a lot of times people who
write html
in addition to using comments to like
write little notes they'll also just use
comments to kind of comment out little
pieces of code so it's kind of useful
right because none of this code is going
to get rendered by the browser now so if
i wanted to maybe try a different piece
of code or you know try something else i
can comment this code out and it's still
going to be there inside of the html
file but it's not going to get used by
the browser and another thing a lot of
people do is they'll put like the reason
why they commented out so you could just
say like uh redoing this or something
and then you know that would mean like
you're rewriting whatever's in here and
you just want to have a backup inside
the comment so that's the basics of
comments they're really simple but
they're also really powerful now
one word of i guess kind of warning and
this is sort of like me just talking
like with my personal opinion i think
when you're using comments you need to
use them sparingly
i think some people have a bad habit of
just writing out like all of these you
know really long comments explaining
things and doing things
you know personally i think the the
purpose of a comment is is to explain
something that can't be explained with
code so sometimes people will write like
a bunch of messy code so they'll write a
bunch of messy html and then they'll
just write a comment above it being like
oh it does this like oh this is the
header meanwhile the code is like you
know a complete disaster it's really
messy i'm a big believer in letting the
html speak for itself and i think it's a
decent philosophy to adopt you know when
you let the html speak for itself you
make sure that you write clean and
readable html and that way when somebody
goes to view your html document they
don't even need any comments to explain
anything because it's all clear you know
what you don't want to be is the guy who
writes a bunch of messy code writes a
comment telling what it does because it
doesn't help anyone out right sure the
comments telling me what this line of
code is doing but it doesn't help me if
i need to go in there or modify it so
before you use a comment try to explain
what you're doing using your html
comments are used for things that can't
be explained with the html and they can
also be used like i said to comment out
lines of code and you know put things on
hold for a second hide them from the
browser you know really this is all just
kind of my opinion and me kind of
riffing about comments but use comments
however you want and
be sure to add them into your html files
to increase your productivity
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about styles and colors one of the cool
things you can do in html is you can
actually style the individual elements
and when you style html elements you can
use something called a style attribute
and you can actually give each of these
html elements certain styling
information
now when we're talking about styling
html there's an entire other subject
that you can get into which is called
css and that stands for cascading style
sheet so in this lesson i just want to
kind of give you an introduction into
how you can use basic css to style some
of these html elements now this isn't a
meant to be a full course on css and in
fact this draft academy course is really
only meant to be used for html we have
another course that talks solely about
css but just know for now i want to
introduce you to the topic of styling
some of your html
you can see over here i have
this
header up here and then i have this
paragraph here in my file
and i can actually give these
two color attributes i can color the
text and i can actually give them a
background color as well so in this
lesson i'm going to show you how you can
start adding some basic colors onto the
elements for your html but again keep in
mind that this isn't meant to be like a
full course on css this isn't meant to
be a full course on styling i just want
to give you guys an introduction
so in here in this paragraph
i can pass this paragraph and attribute
so in html in addition to just defining
the tag you can also give the html tag
certain information these are called
like attributes or properties or some
people call them parameters
i'm going to give this something called
style so i type out style as equal to
and now inside of these quotation marks
i can type out
some different style attributes that i
want to give to this element one of them
is color and color is going to control
the color of the text for this paragraph
i can do a colon and now i can basically
just type out any color that i want so
let's use blue because that's one of my
favorite colors
so now when i refresh this page you'll
notice that this paragraph over here has
turned blue and so instead of just being
that boring black color now it's blue we
could also change it to
red
and now
it will be
red so you can use a bunch of these
different colors and you can change the
color of the text i could also change
something called background color so in
addition to
changing the color to red let's change
the background color to
maybe blue so now i can type out
background hyphen color
and i can pass in another color so let's
make this blue and so now this paragraph
will have its text colored as red and
it'll have its background colored as
blue just like that so you can use these
different color combinations to control
the background of the text
and the color of the text and you can
also use these attributes in other
elements so
for example i could use this same thing
inside of this header right here i could
say
style
and remember this is just a an attribute
that we're passing in i can say color
and now we'll make this green
so i can make this thing green and i can
also use these stylings on these
container tags so up here we have this
body tag i could give this a style as
well so i can say style and why don't we
give this a background color so i'm
going to give this a background color of
light blue so i'll say background
color
light blue
and now what you'll see is the entire
body so the entire body of our html so
all this stuff is going to turn blue and
that's exactly what happened so you can
use this
background color inside of this body tag
to control the background of the website
and what you'll notice is even though we
made the background of the body
light blue
since we made the background of this
paragraph blue as well it's overriding
the styling that we got from the body so
that's how you can use this style
attribute in order to give your html
elements some basic style and if you
want to learn more about styling your
elements draft academy has a full course
talking about css where we get into all
of this stuff styling your html doing
all that but for now if you're just
trying to learn html and i would
definitely recommend learning html first
just know that you can use these basic
coloring styles to change the look and
the feel of your website
now i want to show you a website where
you can go to to find all of the colors
that you can use so
this is a website called w3schools and
you can just kind of google search like
w3school's color list and it'll give you
a list of all these css colors so again
don't worry too much about css just know
that you can use these inside of those
style tags so this is just a full list
of like the name of the color and
if you don't want to pass in the name so
like i could say like aqua inside one of
those style tags and it would color the
text or the background aqua you can also
just put these
hex tags in there so you could copy this
guy and put it in place of the color
name and it's still going to work
so that's just some basics on using
color and styling in html again if
you're just trying to learn html don't
worry too much about styling but i just
wanted to show you guys like the basics
of styling an element just so you can
kind of like get your teeth wet and
start working with
styling inside of your html
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about using various html tags to lay out
the structure of your website now we've
looked at some of these basic html tags
things like body and this html tag we
also looked at things like headers and
paragraphs
all these very basic html tags in this
tutorial i want to talk to you about
tags that we can use to format the
content on our page so these tags are
going to help us to lay out the
different content on our website into
different sections and really when we're
writing html you want to make sure that
you're using the right tags to lay out
your page one of the most common
mistakes that new developers to html
make is that they don't use the correct
tags and they don't use all of the html
tags that they have available to them to
layout their pages a lot of times people
won't use the right tags or they won't
lay out their pages as well as they
could because maybe they don't know
about certain html tags or they just
don't feel like taking the time to use
them but in this tutorial i want to show
you all the tags that you should be
using to lay out your web pages
so
the first thing i want to show you is
how you can start laying out some of the
code inside of your body now most web
pages are going to have three
distinct sections normally there's a
header and the header is like up at the
top and generally the header is an
element that's on every page of your
website so this could be like a
navigation menu maybe it has some
branding information so it has like the
name of the website and maybe a logo and
you'd have links to like other parts of
your websites i mean you guys have seen
a website before you kind of know what a
header of a website's supposed to look
like
the next section is the main section so
this is like the meat and the bones of
the website right this is where all the
content is going to go so maybe you have
would have like an article or you might
have different sections of an article
some images whatever it's like the main
section of the website and the third
section is the footer and most websites
are going to have a footer right if you
scroll all the way down the bottom
there's some additional navigational
links again maybe some branding
information um maybe links to like some
social media pages most websites though
are gonna implement that basic three
section structure the header the main
and the footer and html has tags that we
can use to define all of those sections
so here inside my body i'm going to
start by defining the header and i can
just make
a header tag just like this and we'll
make two of them
and so now any of the code that we want
to put in the header of our website is
gonna go up in here
and now over here
i'm gonna make a main and so we have
these other tags main and
what you want to do is put all the main
content of your website inside of here
and finally we can have the last one
which is the footer tag so
footer and again i'm just going to close
this off footer so we have this basic
three tag layout we have the header we
have the main
and we have the footer
and these are all sibling elements so
they're all they all have the same
parent element which is this body tag
and a good practice whenever you're
using html is to separate the code for
these specific areas so you want to put
all the code for the header of your
website inside the header tags for the
main inside the main tags and the footer
inside the footer tags
inside of these different tags we can
also define
certain things so imagine that inside of
my header tag i had a navigation menu
right a lot of times in a header of a
website there'll be navigation links so
it'll be like here's the home page then
the about page the contact us page
whatever we would want to put any of
those navigational elements inside of
something called a nav tag and this nav
tag is used to store navigational
elements so if you had like you know a
list of different links inside your
website then you could put them here
inside of these nav tags now obviously
the point of this video isn't to show
you like how to build a navigation tag
or a navigation list i just want to show
you what you would need to use for a
structure so i'm showing you like how to
structure this information so any
navigational items like
maybe navigational lists or navigational
links are going to go inside of nav tags
and that's a special tag inside of html
there's also some other tags that we
could use inside of this main so imagine
that i had like a blog website and on my
blog website i had a bunch of blog posts
well one thing i could do
would be to use what's called an article
tag so i can make an article tag and
then inside of those article tags i
could write my blog post so i could make
a tag called article
and down here we're just going to close
this
and so inside of these article tags you
could put all the text for your article
and then the browser would know like
okay there's going to be an article
inside of here we can also use another
tag which is called a section so
generally if you're writing a blog you
might have like different sections on
your website and so we can use this
section tag to break up our article or
really any part of your website into
different sections so once again the
section tags don't have to be used with
the article tag but they just happen to
go together really well and that's on
purpose so i could say section
and
we can close this off
and then any of the code for like the
first section of your blog post could go
in here and maybe i'll have another
section
and again we can just close this off so
you can make as many of these section
containers as you want you can put all
of the content for the section of your
website and usually whenever you have a
different section you'd want to include
a header for the section so you can
include
like an h1 or an h2 or an h3 whatever
header that you'd want to have now i
also want to talk to you guys about
using headers inside of your html
documents and this isn't something that
is required to do but generally if
you're laying out an html page or an
html article you want to be careful with
how you're using your headers so
generally on a web page you want to have
one header one and that header one will
be like the main title for the website
and then below that header one you would
have header twos which would define the
different sections of your website so
you might have this top header one and
then you'd have header twos and then
you'd have another header two down here
and then if you wanted another header
inside one of those sections you would
use a header three so a lot of times
people will recommend using headers in
like a hierarchy fashion so you'd wanna
have like a header one and then header
two
header two
and then inside of here like another
header three so you'd wanna define the
headers of your website in this kind of
like hierarchy fashion and that's not
required like it's not going to change
the performance of your website if you
don't do that but that's sort of like a
best practice that a lot of people a lot
of developers are going to use when
they're designing their websites and
since we're talking about laying out
like the structure of the website i
think that's good information to take
the heart another tag that we can use to
help lay out our websites is called an
aside tag and then a side tag is
basically a tag that you can use for any
content that's not directly related to
like the main content on the page and a
good example of a scenario where you'd
want to use an aside tag might be like
an advertisement so a lot of websites
will have advertisements like you might
be using google adsense or you know
whatever like if you have an
advertisement on your website you could
use an aside tag to define that and the
aside tag basically would just mean like
this content is on the page and it's
getting shown to the users but it's not
directly related to like the core
content of our website so those are just
a bunch of different tags that you can
use to help layout your website and i
would definitely consider using the tags
when you're building the basic structure
of your website one thing that a lot of
people end up doing is they'll just sort
of use like general container tags to
lay out their website so they won't use
the specific html tags that html has
defined for them to lay out their
website and one of the advantages of
using these tags of you know specifying
like this is the section of my website
and this is another section of my
website because you might say like why
do i have to define all those sections
and honestly like using tags like this
isn't necessarily going to change the
look and the feel of your website like
you could create a header a main and a
footer for your website without using
the header the main or the footer tags
the purpose of those tags is one to act
for organization so if you're writing an
html file one of your goals should be to
make the file as readable as possible so
when you write the file you want it to
be able to be read by
either yourself later on or other
developers and when you use these html
tags these structure tags it makes it a
lot easier to tell what's going on right
so i can look at your html and i can
tell like okay here's the header oh
here's the main so this is where like
all of the core content is okay here's
the article and i need to go to the
second section here's the second section
it just makes it easier to
read the file and it just makes the
organization more organized and again
these tags these structural tags aren't
necessarily going to change the look or
the feel of the website but they're
extremely useful another reason they're
useful is for
search engine optimization and search
engine optimization is basically just
how your website is viewed by search
engines so a lot of well there's
actually more to it than that but that's
sort of like the basic ideas like if
your site has good search engine
optimization then it'll be really easy
for search engines like google to be
able to go read through your site and
figure out what it's about and when you
use these very specific
html tags it makes it a lot easier for
something like google to go into your
website and figure out the structure of
your website and figure out where all of
the content of your website is when you
use these html tags something like
google could easily go into your file
and figure out like where the article is
and it can figure out the different
sections of your website and it can
figure out like how your website is laid
out and then it can use that information
to display your website better a lot of
people underestimate the power of these
html tags and so i want to kind of
instill in you guys who are watching
this video the power that these tags can
have you definitely want to use things
like this to lay out your websites don't
listen to people who tell you that
they're not important because they
definitely are important that's the
reason that they're included in html
html is a no-nonsense language there's
not a whole lot of fluff in there so
when html defines something you know
that it's important anyway i would
always recommend laying out your files
something like this using these
different tags if you don't want to you
don't want to but i think it takes a
little extra time but it can really
increase the readability and also the
parsability of your file by like search
engine
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about using links in html a link is one
of the most popular html elements and
it's used to link your website to other
websites on the internet so i could
create a link that would bring my users
to like google.com or facebook.com or i
could link to other pages on my website
so if i wanted to build like a
navigational list i could have links to
the other pages in my website that users
could click and then they go to those
pages you can also link to files things
like images or pdfs and you can create
those links and then users can look at
those images or pdfs so i'm going to
show you how to create a link we need to
use a special html tag called a
and after a we need to pass this tag
some information we need to give it
something called an href and the href is
basically just where we want to link to
so the easiest way to create a link
would be to create like an external link
so
linking to a page that's not on our
website imagine we wanted to create a
link that would go to like google.com
inside of this href i can just type the
address to google.com so i can say https
colon forward slash forward slash and
you need to make sure that you include
this like http or https part a lot of
times when you will give someone a link
like you won't include this you'll just
be like www.whatever
but when you're creating an href and
you're creating a link you need to be
very specific about where you want to go
so you're going to need to include this
part and then i can just type
www.google.com
so what we've effectively done is told
this link attribute that we want it to
link to this address which is google
and now i'll close this and i can
actually close off this entire tag so we
can just make this closing a tag and now
inside of here i can put any text for
this link so we could say for example
google's
home page now i also just want to point
out that inside of these link tags
you can put more than just text so you
don't have to just put text you could
actually put other html elements so i
could put like a header one in here for
example so why don't we do that we'll
make this a header one
and now when i refresh my page you'll
see that we have this big old link over
here it's this big header one and when
we click on it it will link us to
google.com so i'm gonna click this and
you'll see that we get transported over
to google's home page right so we're
over here on google so that's how you
can create a link and basically you can
just go to any website that you want
come up here to the
url bar copy the url including this like
http or https part throw it into the
href of your link and you'll be able to
link there
there's one other thing that we can do
though one thing i want you to notice is
when i click this link it navigates me
away from the website so i click this
and all of a sudden we're on google
in certain cases though you're not going
to want users to navigate away from your
website when they click a link right in
certain cases you might want this to
open up for example in a new tab
and the way that you can do that is by
giving this a
tag another attribute so we can say
um we want to say
target is equal to and now inside of
these quotation marks we want to say
underscore blank okay so when you pass
in this underscore blank value to this
target attribute this is going to
basically tell the browser to open up
this link in a new tab so now when we
open up google it's going to open up
here in a new tab and we still have our
website open so that's one thing that
you can do to make this better and so
again inside of this link i can put any
html elements that i want so i could put
like an h1 and maybe we wanted to like
make this home page bold we could put a
bold tag in here
and you can really like get creative and
like style these different links
different ways you want to so don't be
afraid to put html elements inside of
these a tags because it's definitely
something that you're going to want to
do another thing that we can do is we
can link to other pages on our website
so i'm going to get rid of the text for
that link i'm also going to get rid of
this target blank
and if you look over here in my file
explorer like my little file tree you
can see that in addition to this
index.html file which is the file that
we're using right now i also have this
page2.html and this page3.html
and these are both just like other web
pages that are on my website so any
given website is going to have a number
of web pages you might have like an
about page a contact me page if it's a
blog you might have a bunch of like blog
articles you get the point a lot of
times you're going to have more than one
html file for your website and we can
actually link between those files and
you can use this link attribute to do
that so in here in this href instead of
linking to google using this like
absolute address i can link to those
pages on my website using a relative url
so if i wanted to access this page two
for example let's say that i wanted to
link to page two
because the page that i'm currently on
and page two are in the same directory i
can just type out page 2's name so down
here i can just say like
page 2.html
and the browser will automatically know
that we want to go here to page 2.
so over here i can just type page two
and now in the browser you'll see that
we have a link to page two so when i
click this it'll bring me over here to
page two and you'll notice that inside
of page two i've already set up a link
inside of here so here in page two i
have another link which is just linking
me back to
index.html
and this is a way that we can create
navigation on our site so now i'm over
here in page two and i can navigate back
to the home page so i can navigate
between these two pages on my website
i could also create another link to page
three so let's do that right here below
this page too
we'll make another link this time to
page three
and
one thing you want to notice is that
page three is inside of this directory
so page three is inside of a folder
called der one if i want to link to page
3 i can't just say page 3.html
because the browser is not going to know
where this page 3 is supposed to be we
have to tell it exactly where it is
relative to the current file that we're
on so i can say
dur one forward slash page three and
what this is gonna say is
we wanna go to directory one and we
wanna link to a page inside of directory
one called page3.html
so now we should have a link to page
three and you can see that showed up
right here i can click this and it'll
bring us to page three so that's a way
that you can link to different pages on
your website you can also create links
to
files on your website so in our case uh
we just have this little cat picture and
this is just kind of like a cute cat and
we could actually link to this picture
of the cat
on our website so i'm gonna go over here
into my index file
and we can access this picture the same
way that we've been accessing these html
files so i can just say
instead of dir1 the cat picture is at
the same directory so i can just say cat
and it's a jpeg file so dot jpg
and we can change this to cat
and now i should have a link to this cat
picture so when i click this it'll bring
me to this picture of the cat and i can
look at the cat so that's kind of how
you can link to
external websites other pages on your
website and files on your website so in
addition to a jpeg i could also link to
like a pdf or a word document if i had
it stored on my website it doesn't
matter and that's sort of the basics of
using links in html
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about using images on your website one
of the most common things people want to
do when they have a website is put
images up there and so today i'm going
to show you the basics of working with
images we can talk about resizing images
and basically just placing them on our
html pages so i'm going to create an
image tag down here and an image tag is
basically just less than sign
img
and inside this image tag we actually
have to give it a couple pieces of
information the first thing we want to
give this image tag is the location of
the image that we want to show so when
you have this image tag you have to
basically link it to an actual image and
then the html will be smart enough to go
grab that image and then place it on our
website so i can just say source src is
equal to and then these quotation marks
and inside of these quotation marks we
want to put the location of the image
now one of the most
basic ways to do this is to link to an
image that's on the internet so there's
a lot of images on the internet
obviously and we can actually just put
the address for an image inside of this
source tag and it'll link us to that
image so over here in my browser i just
have some pictures of dinosaurs
and there's a bunch of dinosaurs here um
here's like a t-rex like really scary
so i can just view this image and you
can see up here that this image has like
an address associated to it right so
this image is like you know obviously
it's like this crazy address but i can
copy the address to this image
and then i can just paste it onto
this source attribute so i can just
paste that bad boy right in here and we
got this awesome image and so
when we want to use an image uh in
addition to specifying the source i can
also specify one more attribute which is
called alt
and the alt attribute is basically
what's going to show up if the image
can't be found so one of the problems
that sometimes you'll run into when
you're making your html is that an image
that you're linking to is like either
deleted or it's not there or it can't be
loaded by the browser so for example if
this image of the
scary dinosaur ever like disappeared
like if that person took it off of their
website then it wouldn't show up anymore
and so we have this alt tag as like a
backup so whatever text you put inside
this alt tag will show up if the image
doesn't show up and also it's a good
practice always just have an alt tag and
you want to make this like maybe one
sentence that's like pretty descriptive
so i could just say like a really
scary
dino and now this is like describing the
image and sort of like plain text so i
always want to make sure you have an alt
tag and when we have an image it's just
going to be a single tag so a lot of
times an html will have like two tags
like a starting tag and an ending tag
and we'll put some stuff inside of there
not the case with an image we can just
do this forward slash and we can do a
greater than sign and now the tag is
going to be done so it's just a single
image tag just like this and obviously
it's a pretty long url
now what this should do is it should go
out grab this image and display it on
our website and that's exactly what
happened so this dyno is actually like
pretty big you can see um super scary
but now we have this image on our
website so we can link to this image
another thing that we can do is link to
images that are on our actual computer
so instead of linking to an image that's
on the internet i can just link to an
image maybe that i have like you know
for myself so i'm gonna get rid of this
source here and i have this image on my
little file tree over here it's just
this cute cat
and i can actually take this cat picture
and insert it into my website just like
i did with that picture from the
internet
so inside the source i'm just going to
link to the image of the cat so it's
going to be cat dot
jpeg
and
now i'll change the alt so
we can just change it from like a really
scary dinosaur to a really cute cat and
when i refresh my page we'll have the
cat picture so one of the problems that
you might be noticing with the dinosaur
picture and now with this cat picture is
that they're kind of big right like this
is kind of like a big image and
especially that dinosaur picture that
was huge took up like the entire screen
so one of the things you can do with
images is resize them and we can give
this image tag a couple more attributes
so in addition to defining the source
and defining the alt text we can also
define a width and a height and the
width and the height will control the
size of the image so
i can give this a width you know i could
say actually it's going to be equal to
and we can say maybe like a hundred and
we can give it a height and this will be
a hundred right so we'll kind of shrink
it down a little bit and these like 100
what that means is 100 pixels a pixel is
a unit of measurement
that we can use in html basically like
defines sizes and a pixel is kind of
hard to explain like how big it is
because it's not a
standard unit in other words a pixel
could be a different size depending on
the resolution of the screen that you're
looking at so 100 pixels you know for
the most part it's going to be kind of
the same distance on most web pages but
it's not like an absolute distance of
measurement like a centimeter or an inch
so just keep that in mind so i can say
100 pixel width and 100 pixel height
and now when i refresh my page the cat
is a little bit smaller right so we can
see it a little bit better
but we have another problem which is
that the cat looks
horrible right i mean it's kind of like
smushed in a little bit
and you'll notice if i get rid of this
within the height that i'm actually
changing the aspect ratio of the image
so when i refresh this you see the image
is actually like wider than it is tall
so when you're defining a different
width and a height for an image you want
to be sure to keep the same aspect ratio
what you can do is you can figure out
what the aspect ratio of your image is
so over here in this cat.jpeg you can
see down here that the aspect ratio
for this image is 300 by 200 so it's
like 300 pixels by 200 pixels so it has
like a so it has a 300 by 200 uh you
know aspect ratio or whatever
and we can just keep that same aspect
ratio
inside of our width and our height so
i'm going to put these back in
so if it's 300 by 200 we could make it
um 100 by 66
and this should give us the
correct like aspect ratio right because
that's the same ratio as 300 to 200. so
now when i resize the image it looks
great right it's just it's a little bit
smaller but it's the same dimensions
like it's the same aspect ratio so
that's kind of how you can resize your
images
and you can also use other things with
images so i could combine this image
with a link for example so i could come
over here and we could create a link tag
and we just say a and we'll give this an
href
and inside here i could put like
whatever
link that i wanted to for so for example
i could link this to
like this dinosaur picture right put the
url for the dinosaur in there
and
we can close off this link
and now when i click on the image
it'll bring me to that picture of the
dinosaur so you can make these images
like clickable you can really do a lot
of stuff with these images and you can
embed them inside of other html tags so
i could put like an image inside of
other html tags you know you can put
them anywhere you want and images are
super powerful and you're definitely
going to want to make sure that you use
them on your website and you always want
to make sure that you include this alt
attribute this is really important a lot
of people get lazy and they don't put it
in there but it's really important and
for example if i was to get rid of this
cat.jpeg here in the source you'll see
that now what it does is it just
gives me that alt text so it's really
important just so your website kind of
stays together
in the case that an image link is broken
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about using videos on your website so
i'm going to show you how you can take a
video that you have saved on your
computer and put it into your website
and then i'm also going to show you how
you can include a youtube video into
your website so let's start with a
normal video over here i have this
tutorial.mp4 video and this is just like
one of the tutorials that i did for
draft academy and i want to include this
on my website so i can actually use the
html video tag and it's just going to be
video just like this
and i'm going to give this an attribute
called source so it's going to be src
is equal to and then inside of these
quotation marks i want to type in the
location of the video so the relative
path to the video from the current file
in my case it's just
tutorial.mp4
and then i can close off this video tag
and we're actually going to need an
ending video tag as well
now one thing you might want to do is
put some text inside of these video tags
and this is text that's going to show up
if the user's browser can't display like
videos in a certain format this is kind
of rare like most browsers are going to
be able to display video but just know
that any text that you put in here will
get displayed if the video fails for any
reason
so if i go over here to my website i can
refresh the page and you'll notice that
the video is going to show up and it
shows up but the problem is if i click
on this video
i can't actually play it
right so i keep clicking and the video
is not playing and that's because we
haven't given this video any video
controls
so i can come down here and i can
actually just give this another
attribute called controls and as long as
we type controls in here
now this video will be able to have
video controls so sometimes you might
just want to like store a video on your
website and you don't want anyone to
watch it or whatever and you can just
use that normal video tag but if you
want them to be able to control the
video they need these so now we can
click the play button
and you can see i'm watching the video i
can skip to different parts in the video
over here i can control like the volume
i can make it
full screen or whatever so now we have
like full control over this video
another thing i can do is control the
size of the video so
you can notice the video is a little bit
big if i wanted to give this a different
size i can do that so i can give this
two attributes a width and i can also
give it a height
now one trick is you wanna keep the
aspect ratio of the video so i'm just
gonna give this a width and the height
will automatically adjust to fit
whatever width i'm using so we can give
this a width of like
i don't know 300 and this is going to be
300 pixels so now when i refresh the
page the video is going to be 300 pixels
so it's a little bit smaller a little
bit easier for me to see and you can
control the width and the height by just
using this width property another thing
i can do is control the thumbnail of the
video so you'll notice that when i
refresh the page it just gives me like a
picture of like the first scene of the
video but if i have a specific thumbnail
i can also use that on here so
over here i can just say
poster
and inside of these quotation marks i
can basically pass this an image file so
over here i have this thumbnail image
and this is actually the thumbnail for
that image on youtube so i can actually
open up my index.html file again and i
can just put in here that
thumb.jpg
image and now when i refresh my page
it's going to use that thumbnail for the
video so actually let me make this a
little bit bigger so instead of
just showing the first scene of the
video
like the first image from the video it's
actually going to give me that thumbnail
and that can be really useful another
thing you can do is specify whether or
not you want this to auto play so i
could say over here
auto play and now when i open this page
the video is going to automatically
start playing so that can kind of like
be useful in certain circumstances you
can also tell this to loop so i can say
loop here and now
when the video is finished playing like
if we went all the way to the end of the
video
it's actually just gonna loop back
around so it'll loop around and start
playing again once it gets to the end so
you can see
when i got it all the way to the end
here it started looping around so those
are a couple of the little you know
attributes you can pass it and there's a
couple more i'm not going to get into
all of them so that's how you can take a
video that's just like stored locally on
your computer and
put it on your web page now in addition
to doing that you can also include
youtube videos so this is something that
a lot of people are probably going to
want to do a lot of videos are stored on
youtube and you want to just like
include them into your website and
youtube actually makes that really easy
so over here i just have this dinosaur
video
and if i wanted to embed this dinosaur
video onto my website i can actually
just come down here to youtube
and i can click this share button
and then down here there should be an
option to embed so
over here it will allow me to
click in bed so i can click that and
this is actually going to give me some
html codes you can see over here
this is an html tag it's called an
iframe and basically what the iframe tag
does is it allows you to like peek into
another website so this will like load
up youtube's website into our website
and it'll like center around that video
i'm gonna make an entire html video just
talking about iframes so don't worry too
much about that right now just know that
you can copy this code and then we can
paste it in and youtube actually gives
you options so you can like uncheck or
check these different options and it'll
show player controls or show the video
title and other actions so i'm just
going to copy this and now we can come
over here into our
html
and we can just paste all this code in
and we'll be able to use the youtube
video and one of the cool things about
these youtube videos is you have all of
the youtube player controls so like i
have like the full screen youtube button
i have like the youtube volume button
and all that stuff so it looks really
nice if you're just embedding a video
from youtube
and with these videos you can also
change the width and the height so you
can modify both of these values and make
them bigger or smaller so that's the
basics of using videos i think that
covers most of the use cases either you
have a video that you want to put on
your website or you want to put a
youtube video on your website that's
kind of how you can do both of those
things
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about creating lists in html now html
allows you to list out a group of items
and it provides you with a couple
different tags to do that there's a lot
of scenarios where you might need to
list something out maybe a list of names
or the list of steps in a recipe and you
can use specific tags in html to format
those lists and make them look really
good like i said there's a couple
different types of lists that we can
define and i'm going to show you
basically how you can define a list the
first type of list is called an
unordered list and this is a list that
doesn't have a particular order so
imagine you were making a list of just
like a bunch of different items and they
didn't have to go in a specific order
you can make an unordered list so we're
just going to type ul
and then we're also going to need a
closing tag and we're going to close
that off inside of this unordered list
we can define items for the list so
these two tags are basically like a
container for the list and inside of
here we're going to create something
called a list item so for each item in
the list we're gonna need this
collection of tags which is two list
item tags and in here we can just write
out what we want them to be so i could
write out like a list of fruits for
example so we could say apples oranges
and
bananas right so i'm listing out a bunch
of different fruits and
if i wanted to i could even make these
list items a little bit more complex so
i could include something in here like a
link so i can make a link and we could
give it an href and i'm not actually
going to give this a real
address just because i
don't need to and then i can close off
this link so you can put like html tags
inside of these list items you can
really do whatever you want inside of
there now when i refresh the page you'll
notice that we have this awesome list so
it's listing out all of these items and
you can see this one's a link
and because this is an unordered list we
have these little circle markers that
just marks each list item in the list so
that's how you can define an unordered
list but what if you want to order the
items inside of this list right imagine
that you were writing like a recipe or
something in a recipe you need to follow
steps very specifically so you can't
just skip to like
any step you want
we get to find an ordered list and in an
ordered list we just type o l and that's
gonna stand for ordered list
and now what you'll see is all of the
items in this list are going to be
ordered so it's ordered like one two
three so there you know there's a
specific order assigned to each element
and that order is basically just the
order that these list items appear
inside of the ordered list
you can actually change the style of
list so you notice that we were listing
everything out with numbers i can
actually change that so i can say
type
and we can specify a type so the default
type is going to be one just like this
but instead of one i could say a
and capital a is going to mean that
it's just listening it out in
alphabetical so we have like a b and c i
can also do a lowercase a and that's
going to be lowercase numbers i can do
uppercase i and this is going to be
roman numerals or i could do a lowercase
i and it'll be lowercase roman numerals
so you can change around the style of
the list depending on the type of items
that you have inside
you can also embed these lists so i
could put a list inside of a list item
so let's put a list inside of this
oranges and we could just put another
ordered list right so i can make another
ol
and we'll close this off and i can
define different list items so i could
just say like item one
etc and now we're gonna have a list
inside of this list so
inside of the oranges list item we have
another list and it'll start listing out
things so you can embed these lists all
you want and that can be a really useful
thing to do so ordered lists and
unordered lists are the two most popular
types of lists you'll see in html and 90
of the time you're only going to be
working with those but there's actually
another list that exists
and i just want to kind of tell you guys
about it um you're probably not going to
see this one as much because it's not as
popular but at least you can sort of
learn what it does so it's called a
description list and this is a special
type of list where
you can list out items and then you can
describe those items so you can create a
description list with these dl tags
and
i'm just going to close this one off
and then inside of here we can define
not a list item we're going to define a
description term so this is going to be
d t
and it works just like a list item does
so in here i could just type
apples
and in addition to a description term we
can also give the description term a
description so we can describe the
description term and we're just going to
type dd
um and we'll end this off and so here i
can describe the apples so i could say
like hyphen
they are red or something
and now when i go over to my website
you'll see that we have this apples
item in the list and then we have the
description right below it so i could
add in another one for
like oranges
and we'll have a couple different items
with descriptions so this can be kind of
useful if you want to you know have list
items that have descriptions so those
are the three basic types of lists like
i said for the most part you're probably
only going to be using ordered lists or
unordered lists or at least those are
the most popular that you're going to
see
but description lists exist and they're
really useful as well so you can now
start making different lists in html
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about creating tables in html a table is
basically a way that you can
format information and display it to
your users so if you've ever used
something like microsoft excel or google
sheets you're basically working with
tables and that's kind of what we're
doing here in html
over here i just pulled up some images
of a bunch of different tables and these
are just examples of the kind of things
that we can create when we create our
tables in html so you can lay out
information in this table format
so the way we create table is by using
the html table tag and this is kind of a
complex tag so you want to make sure
that you pay attention to all the
components that go into a table
so i'm just going to create this table
tag
and
then i'm also going to need an ending
tag
and so inside of here we can put
everything that we want to go inside of
our table and the most basic layout for
a table is you're defining a table row
so a table row is like a horizontal part
of a table right it's one entry into the
table and we can define a table row
using these table row tags so
tr
and
ending tags for tr so this is going to
represent like one horizontal row
one entry
into our table and you can define the
individual data for the table in other
words like the individual data for each
column in the table by using something
called table data
so table data
is just going to go inside of this tag
so i could create
one piece of data i'm just going to call
this one
and that would represent one column in
my table so this is like one column and
then if i put another table data it
would be like another column in the
table so i'm going to copy this
and we'll just paste it below here we'll
call this one two
and i'm gonna do the same thing we'll do
one more and we'll call it three
so now when i come over to my website
what i should have is a basic table with
three entries or three columns in one
row of information
and that's exactly what i have so i just
have one two and then three right here
what i could do is i could insert
another row into my table right so i
have this
initial table row right here if i wanted
i could just copy this and i could paste
it right below
and now what we're doing is we're
defining another row so if i refresh my
page you can see we have these two rows
so why don't we change this to four
[Music]
five and
six
and you can see that the rows in the
table are formatted just like they are
here so this row was specified first and
it's showing up first in the table then
we specified this row and now that's
showing up second so that's the basics
of adding data into a table but we can
also take this a step further so if i
wanted to instead of just defining data
i could define
headers for the data so i'm going to
make another table row
and over here
it's going to stay a table row but
instead of defining table data i'm going
to define a table header so instead of
td it's going to be th and i'm just
going to change that on all of these
and so now i'm going to change these so
these are going to be like the titles or
the titles of each column for our table
so i could say like num1
num2
and num3 so
basically they have to list out three
numbers and you'll see here that these
are now like
specified in bold so these would be like
you know the different column titles and
then here we have the information for
each column one of the other things
about tables is that they're really
flexible so if i wanted to come over
here and add in another
column to the table all i have to do is
just
copy this guy and we can just put in
another table
data entry so
we could say like
three and a half
and so now in addition to this three
we're also going to have another entry
in the table
but we don't have to have entries for
like these table headers or for this
other guy you can just put whatever
entries you want and the other cool
thing about tables is that they'll
resize themselves so as i make this
window smaller you'll see that the text
inside of this table is like wrapping
around and that's kind of cool so you
can compress the table and you'll still
have all this information and you can
see that the information below it is
actually moving down to accommodate it
so tables are actually really responsive
so you can define as many table rows and
as much table data as you want and
there's actually another thing we can do
which is add in a caption so the caption
will be like the overall title of the
table
so right here underneath the table tag
i'm gonna put these
caption tags and again this is like the
title of the table so we could just say
like
list of numbers
and now this table will have a nice
caption on it so
you can see the caption will sit like
right in the middle right above the
table and
a lot of times what people will do is
they'll make this like a header so you
can make this a header too
and now it'll be like this nice big
title for our table so it looks really
good so that's the basics of using a
table another thing that people like to
do is define a table head and a table
body and this is just makes it easier
for people to read through the tables in
the html so for example right now it's
like not super obvious that this is
supposed to be the table heading and
it's not super obvious that this is
supposed to be like the content of the
table so you can separate the two
sections by specifying a table head and
a table body so
up here right underneath the actually
right before
this caption we're gonna define the
table head so i'm just going to say t
head
and then below here i'm going to say i'm
just going to end this
and now i'll just sort of indent this so
it looks a little bit better so this is
going to be all the information in the
header of the table
now we can create another tag called a
table body and it's going to be the same
thing i'm just going to say
t body
and then we'll end the t body down here
at the bottom of the table
and again i'm just gonna
kind of indent these things
so it's easier to see so now our table
is laid out with a head and a body
and you'll see that it doesn't change
the way the table looks but it just
allows us to
format it and organize it a little bit
better
now there's one more thing that we can
do with tables which is control
something called call span and call span
stands for column span so
for example i have this
one right here right and this is in the
table you'll notice that when we look at
the table one takes up exactly one
column in the table right so
it's taking up one column and then in
the second column we have two and then
three but i can actually have one take
up more than one column so i can come
over here in the table data and i can
say
call span is equal to and inside of
these quotation marks i can just put an
integer number so i could say for
example two and now this piece of table
data is going to take up two columns in
the table
so you'll see right now it's taking up
one when i refresh the page it's taking
up two now so this one entry takes up
two columns in the table and then
everything else gets pushed over to the
side so i could also say like three
and
now this will take up three columns just
like that so you can control how many
columns each individual table data is
going to take up and that really allows
you to control like every aspect of your
table
so that's the basics of using tables i
mean you want to just make sure that
you're using the right tags i mean
tables at least for me have always been
like kind of daunting because there's so
many of these like little tags in there
but as long as you keep them well
indented and you keep them organized
then you should have no problem
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about containers in html now a
container in html is basically a set of
tags that
wraps other html elements so i can
define a starting and an ending tag and
then inside of those tags i'll just put
a bunch of other html elements
generally when you're writing html it's
good to wrap your html tags in
what we would call like a wrapper tag
and that's basically just like a set of
tags that sort of stores all of the html
and that's because when you start
getting into more advanced html and
you're looking at things like css which
is basically just a language that you
can use to style your web pages usually
if you want to apply a certain styling
to a bunch of different elements you can
just apply it to that wrapper element
and all of the elements inside of it
will inherit that style i don't want to
get too into like css and styling but
just know that a lot of times in html
it's good to wrap up a bunch of elements
into a like overall container
and in this lesson i want to talk to you
guys about
two of the most popular containers in
html which are divs and spans and those
are both sets of html tags that you can
use as containers you can put a bunch of
different html elements inside of a div
or a spam and then you'll you're sort of
like wrapping them up before i get into
divs and spans i want to talk to you
guys about the different ways that html
elements are displayed and this is kind
of an important concept for you guys to
understand the difference between a div
and a span and this is also just an
important concept in general when we're
talking about html so html has two basic
ways that it displays elements and keep
in mind there's more than two you can
get into a bunch of different other ones
but the two main ways like the two ways
that you need to know if you want to
know html are
block and inline so css can display what
are called block elements and it can
display inline elements now block
elements are css or html elements that
take up the entire width of the page so
they're just like a block on the page
and inline elements are elements that
only take up as much space as they need
so you could have inline elements like
sitting right next to each other but you
couldn't have block elements sitting
right next to each other because the
block elements take up the entire width
of the page now different html tags are
going to display differently so some
tags are block tags other tags are
inline tags a good example of this is
paragraphs versus links so if i was to
create two links inside of html
i can just make a link
and it doesn't really have to link to
anything it doesn't really matter
and i'll just say link one
and i'll make another link down here i'm
just gonna copy this one
and we'll call this link two
when i refresh my page
you'll see over here that these links
are actually sitting right next to each
other so link one is sitting right next
to link two and this is a good example
of two in-line elements so these links
are able to sit next to each other
because they're only taking up as much
space on the page as they need right
link one only needs this amount of space
so it only takes up that much space if i
made the text in link one longer
now it's gonna have to take up more
space but you can see we can still stick
link to here right next to it
these are like i said inline
css elements so they can sit in line
with each other or they can sit on the
same line as a good analogy i'm going to
create two html paragraphs so an html
paragraph is in a good example of a
block element so i'm just going to make
one paragraph
and then i'm going to make another
paragraph down here
and i'm actually going to separate these
so what you'll notice is unlike these
links how they sat next to each other
these two paragraphs aren't gonna be
able to do that so you can see we have
paragraph one up here and even though
there's enough room up here in this file
to put paragraph two it's not gonna go
there right so it doesn't matter how
small i make paragraph one like it
doesn't matter how much room there is
over here for paragraph two to go it's
never going to go over there because
these are block elements so block
elements like i said they take up the
entire width of the page and so they
force the next element to go below them
these inline elements don't do that so
with these inline elements you can just
store them right next to each other in
the file and that's the difference
between the two main display types in
html block display and inline display as
long as you understand that concept the
concept of a block element and the
concept of an inline element then you're
gonna understand what spans and divs are
used for
so the big difference between spans and
divs is that spans are inline containers
and divs are block containers so
i can create a span and you just do it
by making these span tags
and we can make an end one
and i can just put some text inside of
here so
let's just say span one and then i'll
make another span down here
span two
and what you'll notice is when i refresh
the page
these two spans in other words the
elements or the text inside of these two
spans is displayed right next to each
other right so this span is an inline
container
when i make two divs i'm going to make
div
and i'll do the same thing so
we'll just put some text in here we can
just say dig one
and div two
and now when i refresh the page you'll
notice that these divs are on different
lines so unlike those spans which are
inline elements these divs are block
elements so the divs can't be on the
same line because they're blocks so div
one is taking up the entire width of the
screen
but these spans can because they're in
line so that's the big difference
between divs and spans is that divs are
inline or no divs are block elements and
spans are inline elements and these are
both containers so we can use spans and
divs as containers right so these are
going to hold either text or they're
going to hold like other html elements
when you start getting into css which is
how you style html you can actually
apply styling to these spans as well so
that's another reason why you might use
a span divs are containers as well but
divs
are block elements so anything you put
inside a div is going to be like a block
element on the page so that's the basic
use for divs and spans you're going to
see these used a lot i think probably
divs are used a little bit more than
spans are just because
the circumstances for using spans are a
little bit more specific than for divs
generally if you're defining a like
overall container in html you just want
to use a div and a lot of times if you
see people using containers in html
they're going to wrap stuff in a div so
just remember that a div is a block
element so anything that goes inside of
a div is going to take up the whole
width of the screen right that div
container itself is going to take up the
width because it's a block element
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
guys about using input tags in html now
input tags are basically going to allow
you to add elements on your page where
users can input information so these are
things like text boxes or text areas or
check boxes radio buttons you know all
sorts of elements on the site that users
can interact with to enter information
now here's the catch when you're
defining these elements in html we're
not actually making them functional so
if i defined like a text box on my
website just because i define it in html
doesn't mean that it's going to work in
other words just because you have the
text box there doesn't mean someone's
going to be able to type in information
and you'll be able to do stuff with that
in order to like get information from a
user through these text boxes you need
to use a language called javascript but
that's a little bit beyond the scope of
this course we're just trying to learn
html so i'm just going to show you guys
the actual html elements that you can
use to define these things like text
boxes and text areas
and then if you want you can go off and
learn javascript and you can learn how
to get input from them so
down here i'm going to define my first
input and all the inputs for the most
part are going to use the same tag so
they're going to use this input tag so i
can just say input
and i need to pass this a
html attribute so i need to give it some
information we can say type and i need
to tell it what type of input i want to
accept and there's a long list of
different types of inputs that you can
accept in html but the most basic one is
just text so this will basically create
a text box for us and you notice that
the input is only one tag it's like a
single tag so we're just ending it
over here there's not like another tag
another ending tag
when i refresh my page you'll see that
we have this text box up here and i can
actually just start typing in whatever i
want inside of here and it's going to be
a functional text box another thing i
can do is create a text box for a
password so
something that is really common on
websites is to have the user enter a
password
and what you can do is you can actually
hide the text that's getting input into
the text box so instead of saying type
text we can say type password
and you'll see what happens when i come
up here
i can type normally in this text box but
when i type down here
it covers these things up so now they're
just like little dots and you can't
actually see
what's being typed inside of there so
that's kind of like a html way of hiding
the input from a text box another thing
we can do is define default content
inside of these text boxes so i could
give this a
value attribute and now we can just
define a default value so i could say
like
enter
your
username maybe this is like a username
prompt and now you'll see that this text
is automatically included inside of that
text box without me having to do
anything
now i can also define something called a
text area and a text area is a lot like
an input but instead of just having one
single line we can have like a huge
block where we can enter text so this
isn't technically an input tag it has
its own type of tag
so it's just called
text area
and in here we can make two tags we're
also going to need a closing tag
and
this text area you'll see is going to be
like a big thing that we can put our
text in so
unlike these two blocks right here this
text area is a little bit bigger and we
can actually resize it so i could take
this text area and make it a lot bigger
on my page just like that
and then i can you know type in whatever
i wanted into here
and that would basically be a place for
me to enter in lots of text you can also
define some attributes for a text area
so i can give this a specified number of
rows or columns so i could say here
rows is equal to
and now we can say like maybe we want it
to be like 10 rows
and we could say columns so remember
rows are going down columns are going
across we can say
columns
and why don't we make this like 30 so
it's really obvious
and now this text area is going to be
really big just like that so it's 30
columns across and 10 rows down
and you know you can kind of just like
see how that works there
and you can also define default text for
a text area so
inside of these two text area tags i
could just type uh you know
enter a
paragraph
and now that text is going to be in
there by default so that's the text area
field and that's pretty fun there's a
couple other uh input tags that we can
look at so there's different types of
input
that you can accept um and i'm just
gonna get rid of this value actually
in addition to accepting things like
text we can also accept something like
a date so a lot of times you might have
someone like enter their birthday or
something and you can see now the
browser is displaying like this little
date input for us and you get this
little calendar widget and this is going
to look different on different browsers
but for the most part if you use this
input type you can control like what the
user is going to input so in addition to
date we could also do like email
and email is actually pretty similar to
just the text box we could also do like
a range so this could be like a range of
numbers and you can see we have this
little slider here we could also do a
file so a lot of times on websites you
want users to upload a file and you'll
see that this actually opens up my
little file browser here and i can click
open and it'll like grab the name of the
file and obviously you know without
javascript or another programming
language you can't actually upload these
files but the point is you can give the
actual input prompt for these files and
you can also define different types of
buttons so i can define like
um
a check box and here we just have a
little box that we could check you could
also define a radio button actually i
want to show you guys the difference
between check boxes and radio buttons
so if i have two check boxes
i can check both of them at the same
time okay just like that if i have two
radio buttons though
and if i give them an attribute called
name so we can name radio button so i
could say
button
and we'll give this one that same exact
name
you can actually only click on one of
these radio buttons at a time so if they
have the same name then i can only click
one at a time so check boxes you can
click as many as you want with radio
buttons though as long as they have the
same name you can only check one at a
time
we can also define different buttons so
i could define like a submit button
that's kind of a popular button that
people have so if you have a form like
an html form you can define a submit
button so i can just say
submit
and now we'll get this nice little
button here for submitting so there's
actually a bunch of these different
input types and i have this web page
open over here this is a web page
on w3schools and it basically just
defines all of the input types for html
so the address is w3schools.com forward
slash tag s
forward slash att underscore input
underscore type and down here there's
this really good list and it just lists
out all of the different types of inputs
that you can have so you see like button
check box color date file text url
all of these different
you know types of like text boxes or
buttons or little elements that you can
use to input information uh in html so i
want to talk to you guys about one more
html element which is called a form and
a form is basically an element that is
going to be used to store all of these
inputs generally so generally if you see
people using this form element they're
going to be putting um
these input tags inside of here so a
form is like a wrapper for a bunch of
user input and
you know as i was saying before like
when you really want to like accept
input from a user
you're going to need another another
language besides html and that's usually
where forms are going to come in handy
because forms can like
give information to like your web server
or whatever but you don't have to worry
about that right now just know that a
form tag is a lot of times acts as a
wrapper for these different input tags
so hopefully you guys you know got
something out of that you can kind of
got a little bit of an introduction into
these different input tags and now you
can style your website so users can
input information into it
in this tutorial i'm going to talk to
you about using iframes in html an
iframe is an html element that's
actually able to display another website
inside of your web page so you can
effectively embed an entirely different
website inside of your own web page
which is pretty cool so you can create
an iframe tag pretty much anywhere in
your site
and it's just
iframe like that and we need to pass
this one attribute which is a source and
this is going to be like the website
that you want to embed so in my case why
don't we just do
the draft academy website
and then i can close off this iframe tag
and you're also going to need a closing
iframe tag so you're going to need one
over here
now inside of these iframe tags you can
put some text and this is text that's
going to get displayed if the user
that's on your website can't view iframe
so maybe their browser just like doesn't
support iframes or maybe they you know
have some option toggled where it
doesn't view iframes basically this code
would be displayed to them if they can't
view it so now when i head over here i
can refresh this page and you'll notice
that inside this little window the draft
academy homepage is displaying but it's
like super small so if you want you can
come down here and we can resize these
iframes so i can give this a
width attribute
and we'll just make it a thousand and i
can also give it a height attribute
and we can make this like 800.
so now this iframe should display a lot
bigger right so now i can see the whole
website so this website is literally
embedded inside of my website so i can
go to all the different pages of the
website it works just like a normal
website would but it's inside of our
website so another thing you can do is
you can control the border so if you
look here on this iframe you can see
there's like a little border around here
it's like this little gray bar it's kind
of hard to see but if you want to get
rid of that there's another attribute we
can pass in we can just say
frame border is equal to zero and now
this will get rid of that little border
so the iframe will just be like
even more embedded inside of the website
now iframes are really great and you can
pretty much use an iframe for any
website but one thing that a lot of
websites will do a lot of like big
websites is they'll prevent
other websites from using their websites
as iframes so like if i tried to
make this
iframe for
like amazon for example amazon.com
then when i refresh the page you'll see
that nothing shows up right i'm not able
to use amazon as an iframe and that's
because they have some setting toggled
where they don't allow their website to
be used as an iframe and
kind of for good reason i mean
one of the problems or one of the
dangers of
iframes is that someone else's website
could pose as another person's website
so i could create a website and just
have an iframe of amazon's website in my
website and i could trick people into
going to my website and they would just
think it's amazon right so they'd be
like oh i'm on amazon this is cool
meanwhile they're on my website and i
could like take their data or you know
do something malicious to them so that's
one reason why people wouldn't want to
have iframes and it kind of makes sense
but in my case like for draftacademy.com
like i have no problem letting people
iframe that so it's available to me yeah
that's the basics of iframes like i said
you know you can resize them you can
move them around and they can be a
really useful feature in your website
in this tutorial i want to talk to you
about meta tags in html
so up here in the head of my website
you'll see that i have this meta tag
right here and this is normally a meta
tag that's included in most html
and it's specifying the char set of my
file right the character set but in
addition to this meta tag we can also
define other meta tags and meta tags
live in the head of the html file and
the head is basically just used to like
define information about the file or do
some different like configuration with
the file and these meta tags are used
for metadata so metadata is like data
about data so we can use meta tags to
define information about this particular
web page
i'm going to show you some of those
different meta tags and we'll talk about
like how they're used and why they're
useful
so
i'm going to make a new meta tag and
we're going to call this one
name so we're going to give it a name
we're going to call it
description so this is going to be the
like full-on description of our website
and over here i'm just going to type
content so this is going to be the
content of the meta tag and here you
could type like
your description
and most websites are going to have a
description and this is something that
can be used by for example a search
engine in order to kind of like help to
figure out what your website's about so
if you give a good description of what
your website's doing then a search
engine could use that information to
kind of figure out where your page
should sit in like page rankings and
stuff like that
and a general rule people usually would
say like maybe 160 characters for a
description is like kind of good
um you don't want the description to be
too long like if the description's over
like let's say 200 characters then most
search engines are just kind of gonna
ignore it or they might even like
penalize you for that in like your
search ranking so description is very
important just make sure you keep it
brief
another meta tag that we can use is
for the author so i can say meta
name and this is going to be
author
actually i don't think i closed this tag
yeah
so you can just close all of these like
this
and then again we can just define the
content so this is going to define like
the con or who the author is so like in
our case it's me
and we can also define some keywords so
this is going to be
keywords and again content so the
keywords can just be stored in like a
comma separated list so you could say
like
html
you know
tutorial
um you know
draft academy stuff like that so we're
just defining this long list of keywords
and again like the search engine could
use those keywords to kind of help index
your site
now one of the things with this keywords
tag is uh like back in the day a lot of
people would just like shove a bunch of
keywords inside of there and then their
pages would get like ranked on google or
yahoo
um like artificially so like all these
pages would get ranked meanwhile they
had nothing to do with the keywords that
were in the keyword tag so i think
probably most search engines at this
point just don't even like bother
looking at the keywords tag but it can
be good to have in there just in case
and another meta tag that we can use um
and this one's actually really important
and this controls how your website is
displayed on
different devices so we can say name
and it's just called a viewport and this
has a couple complicated little options
here that we can configure
so we can just say content and you want
to type out
basically just this so it's going to be
width we're defining the width
and device with
and then
initial
scale
is equal to 1.0 so this is something
that you might see in like html files if
you're looking at them and basically
what this does is it controls how your
website is displayed on different
devices so if you didn't have this in
here and you went to look at your
website on like a mobile device then the
website would just display as it would
on a desktop so it would display like
really zoomed out and really far away
and a lot of times people will design
their websites to be to look really good
on mobile so like if you design this
website to look really good on a mobile
device if you didn't include this line
up in here then it's possible that the
mobile device wouldn't display the
website in that mobile view or display
it like it would on a desktop so like
really zoomed out and it just wouldn't
look good so defining like the width as
the device width so the current device
that's looking at it allows the html to
kind of like respond to the size of the
screen so this is another important meta
tag so these are some basic meta tags
that you can use inside your website and
there's a couple more you can just do a
google search and kind of find like all
of the possible meta tags but i would
say these like
four or five meta tags are like the most
commonly used and the most important for
your website hey thanks for watching if
you enjoyed the video please leave a
like and subscribe